foreign
hey John how are you
Hi how are you better than we deserve
how can we help sure
yes uh so I have a question regarding my
40K of student loan debt once I pay off
roughly 15
000 of other debt do I make a charge to
pay off my 40K of student loan debt or
use a main tax credit program that over
10 years would result in me paying 5 000
the program would refund me my payments
on as a refundable tax credit and should
the program fall through at some point
in three years or so down the road I
plan to have the money saved to pay the
loans back immediately so that I get rid
of that debt but is it a wise thing to
just make a charge at it disregard the
program or Let It Go the 10 years and
pay the 5 000.
over 10 years pay it off John
yep disregard the program
um
for many different reasons but one of
them is just that you have the ability
to pay this off and you will be debt
free on your own regardless very quickly
regardless of a program or the
government's assistant whatever it is
like you you have the ability John to
pay this off and to be debt free and to
move on with your life if Maine had a
program that would give you five
thousand dollars in one year
while you're doing it anyway yeah we
would take it
but Maine has a program that keeps you
in debt for 10 freaking years
I'm not standing around in this sewage
for 10 years
no way yeah get your life back what do
you make
I make 65 000 at this point what do you
do look into I'm an electrical engineer
in the power industry
okay how long you been out of school
uh just a couple years I I did just
switch jobs where I took a little bit of
a pay decrease to just transition to a
better work culture as you definitely uh
elude on in your show yeah because
you're not making much for an electrical
engineer
that's why I'm kind of like whoa
yeah I know I had to take a bit of a pay
hit and transition to um a different
what other debt do you have John
uh my other debt is roughly 15K 12 000
and credit cards to get me through
school and then
um I have 2500 in personal loan yeah you
know most electrical engineers make like
a hundred right
yes uh and that's that's more you have a
couple years of more than a couple years
experience from five and
um maybe a pe2 but
um I'm only a couple years out I would
like to see myself around 80 yeah I'm
making some changes to try to okay good
a few seconds but all right I just
didn't want you to be settling down
there about 65 cents on the dollar where
you should be ending up so because you
got a great degree that's a wonderful
that's a wonderful degree that's right
you got a great choice by the way the
number one career field of people that
become millionaires in America is
engineer
number two is accountant number three's
teacher just to kind of give you an idea
so that's uh of all and we did the
largest study of millionaires ever done
that's what we found so you're in a
great place that's why I'm rooting for
you I think you chose well there but
yeah let's get the debt cleared off as
fast as we can uh and and the
opportunity cost on your life
what you could have been doing with your
life while you were screwing around for
10 years with the state of Maine is not
worth it
get get this stuff paid off yesterday
take six Jobs sell stuff get it cleared
up really really really fast and go have
you a wonderful life yeah